[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Brandon Ne joue Plus les marlou Je n'ai
Plus revu quat balou rien n'a Plus rien
n'a Plus vraiment le mme
Allez vivre légalement les cheveux elle blancs
regretter le noir et blanc pour l'authentique
pour autant quand emporte le
vent miss dep che toi et remet ta
robe de taa Tous les Plus grands Air
d'opéra on des rand de r serorita dép toi
Je suis un peu plus vieux que toi Je Ne
vais Plus Au cinéma on a fermé la
[Applaudissements]
lambra n'est Plus Sur sa mon IL se meur
dans un tango
dernier sanglot
Tous les Indiens vivent à l'ouest du monde.
Rivière
Bravo va Plus rien va Plus mme chez les
gringos miss dép toi et remet ta Rob
de tap Tous les Plus grands G d'opéra
ont des rand de romba signor de pêche toi
Je suis un peu plus vieux que toi Je Ne
vais Plus Au cinéma
dans une ferme la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ver